The European elections are in less than 2 months,
but are you well registered on the voters' lists
and do you know how to do it?
If not,
To be able to vote in the European elections,
you must be of legal age,
not having been deprived of his or her right to vote by the
Justice
and be registered on the famous electoral lists.
If you are a European citizen,
no problem voting
in France in the European elections,
provided that you are registered to vote
French.
If you are not registered,
you have until May 1st to do it online
on the 3 W site
public service point FR
and until May 3 if you prefer to do it in town hall
to check if you are registered.
2 solutions,
go to the town hall or go to the 3 W site
public service point FR.
1 time connected,
you can check
if you are well on the lists
and even consult the municipality where you will vote,
because you can very well be registered
but not in the right commune,
for example after 1 move.
This is what we call thugs.
According to Lindsay,
indeux-mille-vingt-deux,
this was the case for 16% of users
and even nearly 40% of young people.
If this is your case,
don't panic,
you can correct your registration at the town hall
or online.
Finally,
if you are not available to vote on D-Day,
you can make 1 proxy,
or
by moving to 1 police station or 1 gendarmerie.
Either on the 3 W site
Point, my proxy,
point goove,
point FR.